here's what's in theaters this weekend a  major weapons test is imminent we need  to know how to destroy the force returns  in the action-packed prequel Rove won a  Star Wars story go rogue in IMAX check  local listings for a Showtime near you  in whites letters who are they - time  love death a grieving father comes  face-to-face with the mysteries of the  universe in the heartwarming drama  collateral Beauty it's there the  collateral beauty these dreams that we  keep running into each other maybe it  means something out it yeah from the  creator of whiplash comes lala land a  romantic musical that will have your  toes tapping here's this week's fantasy  patient so what's your weekend ticket  going to be let us know by commenting  below see you next time on weekend  ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]